hey Vsauce Michael here in 1924
psychologist carnie Landis drew lines on
people's faces and then photographed
them in various scenarios to study
facial expressions but he didn't use
actors and he didn't tell the
participants to pretend to feel emotions
instead he subjected them to actual he
had them do things like smell ammonia
look at pornographic images and even
reach their hand into buckets of wet
slimy frogs his most intense directive
involved ordering them to take a knife
and while being photographed cut off the
head of a living rat seriously most
initially refused to cut the head off
but eventually two-thirds agreed to do
as they were told
including a thirteen-year-old boy
referred to the psychology department by
a doctor for high blood pressure thought
to be caused by emotional instability
many believe his inclusion in Landis's
experiment was an accident
if replicated today Landis might be
arrested but what is psychologically
arresting about these images is that the
unease and disgust and fear they show is
real it's disturbing but fascinating
we are paradoxically drawn towards some
pretty repulsive things car accidents
car chases the possibility of a crash or
a fight or a natural disaster I mean not
one that hurts anyone of course but one
that's exciting celebrity scandal drama
disfiguration true crime war and gore
the McCobb like the kang li a trumpet
used during hem alayan buddhist rituals
that's made out of a human leg bone we
often feel guilty for being interested
in these type
things after all they are unpleasant but
yet we can't look away why well there is
no single reason there are many of them
but they can be Nold into a mnemonic we
like disturbing things because we like
to scream
they give us strength catharsis reality
exploration acceptance and meaning
watching someone eat gross tasting jelly
beans or a ghost pepper or a spoonful of
cinnamon or suffer in more extreme ways
is a kind of strange thing to like to do
but it's part of what keeps us alive we
are curious even if the outcome could be
bad we often find uncertainty more
unpleasant than unpleasant certainty at
least if we look we know there's a
neurological basis for exploring in the
face of danger we become more attentive
and alert when we are frightened which
makes sense neurotransmitters like
norepinephrine and dopamine are released
when we are scared physically and
mentally preparing us to take on a
threat or successfully escape from it
dopamine is famously part of the brain's
reward system dopamine is released in
response to pleasurable things like sex
and food but that doesn't mean that our
brains find disturbing things
pleasurable it's more interesting than
that when dopamine systems are inhibited
in laboratory animals they will cease to
seek out food and literally starve to
death
because they no longer find food fun no
if food is placed in their mouths they
will consume it and express signs of
satisfaction evidence like this suggests
that the brain contains systems that
motivate seeking approaching and
curiosity for their own sake this has
implications in the study of compulsive
behavior just because you want to do
something doesn't mean you like it the
rush of chemicals into our brains and
bodies when we are scared help us when
the threats are real but if the threats
aren't real or if we are safely distant
from them and merely spectating the same
chemicals still appear making us more
attentive more curious and making it
more difficult to look away in the early
1900's Eugen Luigi ion published
incredible images of corpses he cut into
stackable slices the images are
amazingly low calm but yet utterly
fascinating and a wonderful reminder of
what we are literally made of we often
feel like we need an excuse like
Halloween or anatomy homework in order
to look at things like that without
coming across as a total weirdo I mean
come on if you look too interested in
the McCobb it might look like you are
into approve of or enjoy the gruesome
funny enough that guilt may very well
fuel our desire to look in the first
place sometimes pressure to not do
something can actually make people more
likely to do that thing it's called the
boomerang effect there are many
different ways for things to boomerang
one is the Streisand effect when trying
to suppress something unintentionally
makes it more widely distributed in 2003
Barbra Streisand sued to suppress a
photo published online as part of a
California coastline preservation
project one of the photos the one she
was trying to get rid of showed her
house within a month of the lawsuit
going public nearly half a mil
people had flooded the website and
downloaded the picture before the suit
only six people had downloaded the image
two of which were her lawyers in a
similar fashion social pressures and
taboos against viewing disturbing things
can make them more interesting rarer and
so a more valuable commodity and also
free in that deliberately viewing them
can demonstrate to ourselves and others
that we are free and can do what we want
disturbing things can also make us feel
stronger because their repulsiveness is
a challenge blend sparks at Purdue
University has studied the way
terrifying films affect us after
watching them viewers often feels
stronger satisfied that they didn't
chicken out that they made it through
they conquered something disturbing and
were able to handle it it's almost a
form of practice as Stephen King put it
we make up Horrors to help us cope with
the real ones on the more negative side
following celebrity scandals or seen
defeat on the faces of the rival team
can make you feel pretty good
it's called schadenfreude which means
harm joy getting pleasure from others
misfortunes social comparison theory
describes and predicts behavior like
this although grades and rankings cause
anxiety we nonetheless possess a drive
to seek out evaluations of ourselves in
comparison to others we especially enjoy
the evaluations that put us on top now
causing other people to be less well off
sort of makes sense
under this lens if it's relative
happiness you're concerned with trolling
or harassing or griefing other people
sort of works it doesn't make you
happier but compared to the people
you're annoying you are less annoyed so
yeh viewing scenes of anger and
vengeance and violence that don't even
involve us
can nonetheless cause our own anger and
aggression to burn off as though they're
being satisfied it's called catharsis a
cleansing a purification creating images
and movies and stories that play with
our emotions might be grasping at
low-hanging fruit a task beneath such
logical creatures as ourselves or it
might be a powerful demonstration of the
fact that we have control or at least a
leash around how we feel we condemn the
actions of serial killers but
nonetheless often treat them like rock
stars
websites like Red Rum autographs and
serial killers Inc sell autographs
souvenirs trinkets and works of art made
by real serial killers some call it
murder velia on a spectrum of petty
thrills and morose voyeurism to complete
overwhelming obsession and fear our
relationship with the morbid is
complicated but it is under our control
if we're aware of our actions one of the
most constructive and socially important
uses of the morbid is the facilitation
of meaning acceptance and empathy in his
book everyone loves a good train wreck
Eric G Wilson says that our attraction
to the McCobb is on some level a desire
to experience someone else's suffering
morbid curiosity is often about the
imagination imagining what it would be
like to be that other person what if
that happened to me could it happen to
me empathetic feelings remind us that
our time is limited and that we are
fragile and in doing so bring us closer
together
sure enough the last movie I watched
that made me want to go out and hug the
very first friend I could find wasn't a
happy feel-good comedy instead it was
Louis rose sombre extreme love dementia
viewing unpleasant things doesn't always
make them less unpleasant or any less
real but that's not always the point
morbid curiosity is
also about acceptance remember our
brains are wired with motivations to
explore unpleasant things because doing
so can be preferable to ignorance
gawking at morbidity is often about
asking why there must be a reason a
meaning behind all of this when tragedy
strikes or Horrors are revealed we
listen to experts give opinions
neighbors describe the killer we look
for signs that were missed and
confirmation that others feel the same
way we do that people are helping while
making sure justice is served
kaitland OD the host of ask a mortician
here on YouTube just wrote a phenomenal
book smoke gets in your eyes and other
lessons from the crematorium in the book
she says accepting death doesn't mean
that you won't be devastated when
someone you love dies it means you will
be able to focus on your grief
unburdened by bigger existential
questions like why do people die and why
is this happening to me
death isn't happening to you death is
happening to us all that's heavy stuff
but acceptance like that is one of the
greatest things Mormon curiosity has to
offer and don't worry there's a funny
side to all of this or at least a funny
side related to this and how morbidity
helps us make sense of the world a study
in Finland found that children were four
times as likely to be scared by their
usual television programs if a parent
was in the room it surprised researchers
but one explanation lies in the Oh mom
flinched theory the idea is that to a
young child almost everything is brand
new but parents are older they're wiser
they know what's normal and if they are
scared of what
TV oh how we feel and how we feel about
how we feel is to a large degree learned
there's a theory about the origin of
humor called the encryption theory of
humor it suggests that one of the great
rolls humor plays is in measuring who's
inside and who's outside who's similar
and who's socially or ideologically to
different jokes test what researchers
call unstated common knowledge the
teller and listener both share so might
we be morbidly curious for the same
reason we enjoy telling jokes jokes
assess underlying shared attitudes
morbidity helps us assess shared
underlying attitudes of an existential
variety morality and justice whether
it's used for empathetic or exploitative
reasons morbidity and laughter may share
a similar adaptive role we are morbidly
curious because we like to scream but
more strangely the yuck and the yuck
yuck
overlap and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]